coronav virus cases in the US are on the
rise with 37 States seeing an uptick in
Daily cases over the past seven days and
one of those States is right here in New
York where Governor Andrew Cuomo
recently unveiled new lockdowns for nine
so-called hotspots where cases are
surging New York reported more than a
thousand new cases yesterday granted
that's a big decrease from the high of
more than 11,000 back in April when the
state was the eper center of the
outbreak here in the US still nearly 900
people in New York are currently
hospitalized with the virus Cuomo
discusses what he has learned in his new
book American crisis Leadership Lessons
From the co 19 pandemic and Governor
Cuomo joins us now good morning Governor
uh I want to get right to it because
we're at a delicate moment here in this
country everyone seems to agree the fall
is going to be challenging what are you
doing to
prepare um good morning good to be with
you well look the experts all said that
the fall was going to be challenging
right the weather changes people go
indoors schools start Etc uh and we're
anticipating that in New York Statewide
we have one of the lowest infection
rates in the United States of America
and New Yorkers are very proud about
that we had the highest rate of
infection when this started because we
were ambushed by the virus now we have
one of the lowest but what we're doing
is we are targeting what we call Micro
clusters so when we see a small group of
cases we are the firefighters who rush
in to stamp it out before it takes off
yeah so we have several areas in the
state that are small they're about uh
two 2 square miles but wherever we see
cases popping up that's where we jump
yeah Governor they are small but people
are concerned about the fall as you
mentioned the markets are concerned the
rest of the country is concerned the
places that are uh restricted now those
hot spots they have about 6% positivity
rate in infection rate of 6% can we
assume that will be your benchmark for
deciding if a Statewide shutdown is
required well the uh our numbers are so
low relative to other states our worst
areas are about 5 6% many states are
above five uh 6% across the entire state
right uh so what we do is uh our overall
infection rate is about 1% which is very
low see but Governor if the overall rate
as you mentioned other states are
already above 5% these hot spots are
above 6% and they've got restrictions
would we see a second shutdown if the
state level the overall numbers get
above 6% same
standard oh well look I never want to
get that high so what we're going to do
is uh do more restrictions on any
clusters that start and that's how you
stop it from getting statewide right
that's one of the points let's learn the
lessons from the past seven months uh
this is Aja vu all over again we're
talking we're having the same
conversation we had when this virus
started we've learned a lot let's
acknowledge what we've learned you know
uh otherwise we're just going to repeat
the whole situation in the fall we're
still talking about whether or not we
should wear masks I mean how ridiculous
no it it is a remarkable thing but I do
want to talk about Lessons Learned and
and it would seem that one of the bigger
mistakes we can all agree on was back in
March the state of New York sending sick
coid positive seniors back to nursing
homes thousands died in those nursing
homes no matter how you counted a big
portion of the overall death toll
knowing what you know now looking back I
I got to assume you would do things
differently uh look there's no doubt
that we learned lessons on the nursing
homes the first point is uh that's how
we were introduced to this virus right
it was a nursing home in the state of
Washington the virus prayed on the week
and it prayed on people in nursing homes
and most of the lives lost the single
greatest percentage is in nursing homes
and that's true all across the country
uh and there's also no doubt that we're
in this hyper poitical environment so
everybody wants to point fingers uh New
York actually we're number 46 out of 50
in terms of percentage of deaths in
nursing homes 46 out of 50 so uh yes
people died in nursing homes uh yes uh
we've learned a lot of lessons but 46
out of 50 uh it's not a predominantly
New York problem if we had to do it all
over again Tony I would do things
differently uh I would not have waited
for the federal go yeah you made that
clear in your book uh about you made
this is Gail speaking to you Governor
you made it very clear about Lessons
Learned and the mistake you made the
mistakes you've made but what I found so
fascinating about your book you took us
through a Tik Tok from the beginning how
it started what we were learning I felt
in real time we were learning what you
were thinking and the decision-making
process you said listen there's no blue
print for any of this you said we had to
you had to develop trust and Trust leads
to truth so 19 days in when you ordered
that
lockdown how did you think or did you
think people would pay attention to what
you were saying because none of us had
been in this situation
before you know Gail you rais a very
good point uh and it was unspoken at the
time this was not really about
government action uh this was I yes I'm
governor of the state of New York but I
I I can sign piece of paper that orders
people to stay home and orders
businesses closed and schools closed but
that doesn't mean they're going to
follow government uh frankly doesn't
have the uh the authenticity to take
these kinds of actions or the
enforcement capacity so it was really
about getting people uh to understand
the problem so that the people actually
agreed to take these actions to protect
themselves that's why it was unlike
anything I've ever done before it was
people understanding the facts and
sharing information and informing
themselves so they could do the right
thing to protect their own family but
you know and that was my posture all
through this yeah I felt though many
people felt you were the only one who
was telling us anything you know you
gave us hard truths you didn't try to
sugarcoat when when we needed to hear
the truth and there and you also talked
about your own vulnerabilities you are a
Bonafide girl dad you've got three
daughters that the even they were saying
you Dad what's the deal your brother
Chris Cuomo went through a very nasty
battle you had a mom who you hadn't seen
like many people hadn't seen their mom
and you exposed a lot of your own
vulnerabilities and I'm wondering as a
governor of the state how you were
navigating that also navigating your own
personal duties
too yeah uh you know Gail you're right
uh I I had a sense once I knew what we
were looking at uh and the consequences
I knew it was unlike anything we had
ever done before and I think the rule
book went out the window uh people in
this partisan atmosphere they're not
going to listen to a politician they're
not going to listen to a governor nobody
trusts anyone I said to the people uh
basically uh this is Andrew um my mother
is Matia these are my daughters this is
my situation my situation is like your
situation I'm in the same place that you
are in this is not just about
information it's about emotion and I'm
feeling the emotion that you're feeling
and I'm afraid for my family yeah so
let's work this through together and I
will tell you the truth so help me God
good bad indifferent I'm not going to
filter facts facts are facts but let's
share and work together and get through
this yeah and that put you and that's
that's still where we are yeah a lot of
us are still afraid that put you at odds
with the president of the United States
you write this the difference between
Trump and a great leader is like asking
him not to act in his self-interest is
like asking a skunk not to smell that's
kind of like poking the bear gun are you
getting ready for the incoming that's
coming your way
shortly look I've been taking incoming
from day one Gail right all right yes uh
I have no problem taking the incoming
but uh I think at this point I want
people to have the information to
protect themselves got it uh everyone is
worried about their family get the facts
inform yourself and that's what I'm
trying to get done thank you Governor
thank you very much the name of the book
is American crisis it's on sale today
where wherever you like to buy your
books thank you Governor k